That was it!
I didn't even know that was possible!
So we have flown over to Los Angeles
For the biggest YouTuber ping pong event tournament
Hosted by Airrack
Let’s go!
Twelve creators battling for $120,000
and during their matches we were giving them different distractions.
Check out the full tournament
on Airrack's YouTube channel!
But before the event started
we challenged the creators to do some trick shots!
I think they are all inside waiting for us!
Yeah let’s go!
I’m gonna hit the ping pong ball behind the back!
Aah behind the back!
Yeah watch this!
Allright!
I’ve never done this in my life
Watch this though!
Oh I have to move my arm..
Yeah you gotta..
Ooh he got it!
Let’s go!
Nice!
I feel like a superstar, dude!
That was good, that was fun.
You had a good touch for it!
Yeah thank you, thank you so much!
The challenge is...
...that
Okay.
One bounce, edge, one bounce, edge and one bounce.
Am I trying to beat you?
No you don’t have to beat me!
You can do a challenge!
Okay.
It’s harder than it looks!
I can bounce it on one side!
Oh man..
Yes!
And there we have it!
Look at that!
Only took like one minute to learn!
Yeah that was impressive!
Woo!
Between the legs shot
Okay.
Sounds easy!
Haven’t practiced that one but I’ll give it a go!
Through the legs!
Here we go!
This is so hard!
Need some practice..
No that’s not through the leg..
Ooh nice!
Ooh good!
Four!
Aah you got to use that in a match!
That was pretty impressive!
That’s kind of fun!
That’s a workout!
I’m sweating are you sweating?
Not really but..
He’s like..
Youre’ just...
But seriously I was impressed you got four in a row.
Me too!
Honestly I had no idea I would actually do that!
But you killed it
You made that look easy!
I missed one so..
You have to do it with two balls!
Yeah you’re going to have to do better!
Did you see how he did it?
I need like the whole freaking set..
Every ball here please!
Thank you!
Oh I only have two?
Oh yeah!
Hit it with some spin!
That almost hit it!
I think you’re about 11 tries
Twelve tries!
Got it!
That was impressive!
Thank you, thank you!
Allright so you know the challenge?
I’m scared!
I thought around the world was kinda like when you just hit it and then we run around like the..
You’re telling me we have to spin it around the net?
Yeah.
Yeah no I got this!
I’m sweating tits right now!
You two can have a battle who gets the best around the net shot
Okay.
Ooh that was close!
Allright I’m getting it now!
You got it you got it!
Okay no I’m not..
Ooh that was the closest one so far!
I feel it was like semi-decent..
You think you can do better than Alex?
Yeah!
I’m trying to curve it..
Oooooh!
In the camera, in the camera!
It was lucky it was lucky, okay?
It was a good try though!
Thank you, it’s an A for effort.
Allright so..
The idea is to smash this.
Let's see.
Not first try?
That's how you do it
I get two tries?
Yeah.
If you do it in one I'll be really embarrassed
Okay make him look bad..
Miikka?!
That was better than you!
So guys I'm the new champion!
I think Pongfinity has a new member.
I’ll just, you know I’ll leave my..
Check me out next week guys!
Mama I made it!
Now you need to go further.
You go first.
Oh no!
It’s turning into a competition
Come on Miikka!
Oh no!
I’m nervous
Miikka is sweating there!
I know!
Okay one more and then we are even.
It was like this
It hit the cone!
I’m gonna tap out right there
Allright.
Cause I don’t think it’s gonna happen.
That was really good!
I skimmed it!
So 1-1.
What’s the final challenge?
I’m a little warm now!
We haven’t done anything on the table yet
I wanna try to receive one of your serves.
Yeah that would be good
That’s the final challenge!
Okay one serve, receive one serve!
Okay!
What was that?!
Okay..
What the..
It’s like..
Okay can I try those after?
Yeah you can!
You just need one lucky return!
I know I know..
Thanks, that was good!
Hug!
You did really well!
Thank you I appreciate that.
The idea is to play with three balls at the same time.
Oh 3? wow.
Yeah, you think you can manage?
I think maybe we did two, never three!
Otto and Emil are gonna show you the example and then you can try
Just a really light hit, try to keep the rhytm.
Yeah I think you are ready for the third one!
You have the two now!
Ooh there we have it!
Niice!
Aah that was good!
Playing with three balls, now you can do anything!
Good job!
Oh got him running!
You guys caught that there it is!
Do you wanna try an around the net?
Is that where we are gonna go like this?
Yeah, go around the net.
You can be standing somewhere like here.
Oh this is where I’m gonna do it?
Keep it a bit more closed and then it goes lower.
Yeah yeah that’s right!
That was it!
That was the..
That was a roller!
Oh man!
An actual roll, I didn’t even know that was possible!
That’s wild!
That was the sickest shot!
You guys are so talented
Thank you for showing me.
That was amazing!
And it’s not magic this is not one of his illusions.
No editing, allthough maybe in the future we’ll do something like that.
Otto’s best serves
Okay let’s try!
Can i try to return those?
Yeah!
Oh Wow
It’s like it twists in mid-air
Dude!
I’m hitting that
I know for a fact
I thought I had to hit it up because I
kept hitting it down.
I got this
What!?
Bryce how was it returning those servesI
I was trying I actually was trying and
I couldn’t do it
He did it!
Good job bro!
Comment below who you think did the best.
And big thanks to Airrack for hosting this tournament,
inviting us
It was so much fun,
go and check out his channel and subscribe there as well!
Until next time!